you
Good evening everyone it is 530 on Thursday August 27th
2026 and this meeting of the Huntsville City Council is
Called to order welcome to everyone who has joined us in the chambers or who is joining us remotely
All members of the council are present. We will begin as is our practice with an indication authored by one of our
Huntsville, Alabama public safety chaplains tonight
We have Rachel Harper with us and that will be followed by the Pledge of Allegiance
Offered by councilmember John Meredith all those who wish to and are able to do so please stand for the invocation and the pledge
Father we come to you tonight as a grateful people for all the many blessings that you have
afforded us and for the
Opportunity that we have each and every day to live in such a great nation
Father I'm thankful for our leaders and for their hearts to serve Lord and I ask father that we never ever take lightly the
Responsibilities that we have as servant leaders. I pray for continued blessings
Over our city and for wisdom Lord over our City Council in decisions made tonight
Lord we pray for safety for all the men and women
Who who give their lives who their lives on the line every day for your service and to?
Protection of us Lord. We just ask all these things in your precious name. Amen
To the flag of the United States of America and to the Republic for which it stands one nation under God indivisible with liberty and justice for all.
Thank you Chaplain Harper. Thank you. Mr. Meredith
Councilmembers you have the agenda
Before you please note that item 8a will require executive session
Are there any changes or additions to be made to the agenda?
Hearing none of the agenda will be approved
You also have the minutes of the regular meeting of the City Council held on August 13
2026 are there any additions or changes to be made to those minutes?
Seeing none the minutes will stand approved
We have two recognitions tonight 6a is a presentation recognizing the 65 year legacy of Big Ed's pizza and mr
Little I believe you will be making that presentation
Our friends from Big Ed's here pizza
It doesn't come on down sir
I
If you didn't hear he said he didn't bring us any pizza, so we're gonna go ahead and vote this out
We'll swing by thank you. I'd like to change my vote to a name
If he didn't bring us food then I'm changing my vote to now
So just saying so yes, well that's that's a holding on to a grudge if you're bringing back Britlands
Yeah, oh, yeah, well, I'm sure everybody that's lived in Huntsville for any amount of time has heard of Big Ed's pizza
Celebrating 65 years of business in Huntsville, which is quite a testament to good pizza. I did a little
Research and I can only find about five or six businesses that are still around as long as Big Ed's so that's really great
And this is a certificate recognizing that great
The outstanding food and tradition and community service and assigned by everybody on the council and the mayor too
Yes, congratulations. So much. Yeah. Yeah
You
Congratulations
6b is the presentation recognizing the dedicated volunteers of the Chaffee community and it is my honor to make that presentation
Representing the Chaffee community tonight. We have mr. Lyle Boyles and mr. Bill Gould mr. Boyles. Mr. Gould. Will you come up, please?
You
If you didn't know the Chaffee community has the one of the oldest and largest
civic associations in the community
They are a neighborhood that is well connected. They are a neighborhood that really cares about their community and tonight we are honoring them
particularly for the unique service that they provide to caring for Logan Park in
Collaboration with parks and recreation. So mr. Gould, would you share with us what it is you do? Sure. So
starting in 2011
The CNCA the Chaffee neighborhood civic association reached an agreement with the city to take
Responsibility for opening and closing and basically tending to the park keeping an eye on things letting them know our problems and issues
Calling in when somebody was in there when they shouldn't be and activities going on
Lyle here was one of that
First group he was the actual founding member of it and he's still in the rotation today
Every once in a while if it gets his key, we've got to get it for him. But but a group of six teams
Every week every six weeks you get a rotation
You take that week with a partner and somebody opens it in the morning opens the restrooms checks the facilities to make sure that it's good
And then somebody else or that same team Lyle does it by himself. He can't find a good partner, I guess
We close it up every night when we see something we reach out
So the the partnership with the Parks Department is amazing
We are truly partners if we need something we just reach out David Della. Sir is my favorite pen pal
I send him a note saying there's a toilet that's running or there's a trash can that somebody took home as a souvenir and the next
Day, it's done. It's fixed
When we have issues we can reach out to the police
We had a somebody who was living in the keeping their car living in the park while they were visiting their girlfriend down the street
The police department came over and helped us to clean that up. We've been doing that now for 15 years
We plan on doing it for a bit longer and we greatly appreciate the partnership and the support that allows us to keep our precious
little park safe and clean and a great place for the families to spend time
So, thank you and I have ten certificates here that I hope you will share with with all the folks who are involved
Yeah, if I could those those people are
Most of them still getting out of work when we're starting this so it's not a bunch of retirees that just hang around and that's nothing
To do but open and close the park. They fit it in amongst everything else first thing in the morning last thing at night
We make sure that it's taken care of and while we were talking before the meeting started about why this is so important
And so do you want to comment on that?
Do you don't just take care of the park just to make it look nice?
Well, it's significant in the fact that the park was really
It's secluded off of the South Memorial Parkway it was dark
There was a lot of nonsense going on in the park vandalism things of that nature and as a result of doing this now for
These years that significantly reduced all of that and again
We're so grateful to the city for the support we get from several the departments not just parks and recreations
But general services and others are in there and we do appreciate that and thank the city for that
And we're sharing this tonight not just because we want to recognize the volunteers and again here are the certificates
We hope you'll share that but this is a model. We hope other communities can use
So thank you both for your service. Thank you to all the volunteers the chaffee volunteers and for the work that they do
All right moving on
We have 8a matters with outside legal representation
8a is a resolution authorizing the mayor
To enter into a legal services agreement with the city of New York City
And the city of New York City is going to be the first to enter into a legal services agreement
With the city of New York City and the city of New York City
Authorizing the mayor
To enter into a legal services agreement with Riley and Jackson PC and affiliated co-council
for the investigation and prosecution of claims relating to the fire apparatus
manufacturer antitrust litigation
Council members we have been informed that there is need for executive session on this item before we vote
So mr. Riley, could you share with us that rationale?
Certainly. Thank you council president
the council the
Item number 8a tonight is a matter with outside legal representative which will require
executive session and which we will request
Executive something session is something that is covered by the Alabama Open Meetings Act found at section 36 25 a
7 of the code of Alabama
Which provides that executive sessions may be held by the council but only for the purposes
Enunciated therein there are some ones listed the pertinent provision for our consideration tonight
For my opinion is found at subdivision a 3 which is to discuss with the council's attorney the legal
ramifications of and legal options for pending litigation or for
Controversies not yet being litigated but imminently likely to be litigated or
imminently likely to be litigated if the government body pursues a particular or proposed course of action
Before you go into executive session the law requires
That the governmental body shall receive either a written or oral
Declaration that will be reflected in the minutes from an attorney licensed to practice law in Alabama
It that this exception is applicable to that plan discussion and I for the purposes of that
Requirement am a lawyer practiced for a long long time in the state of Alabama. So I've been licensed for sure
And I've confirmed this item does fall within the exception that we just discussed allowing
executive sessions
and
That I'm qualified to make that that determination
So if you would ask for a motion, thank you. Mr
Riley the chair moves that the City Council go into executive session to discuss with our attorney the legal ramifications of and legal options for possible
litigation second for mr. Meredith is there any discussion question? Yes, mr.
I think just for the record mr. Riley, there's a rally at the law firm, but that is not related to you, correct?
That is if it is it's so far back neither of us know so to my knowledge
There's no representation whatsoever. No rec no
Relation whatsoever. Thank you for clarifying that any other discussion all in favor, please indicate
Madam president, we need a roll call vote for this
We
A roll call vote has been requested. Mr. Meredith. How do you vote?
Mr. Clean, how do you vote? Mr. Little? How do you vote?
Miss Watkins, hi and the chair votes. I we have unanimous consent to go into
Executive session we will reconvene the public meeting when we return
Do you have an estimate of the time?
We do not
we will
I would estimate between 15 to 30 minutes. Thank you. We will likely on the short side of that
We will reconvene at the conclusion of our executive session
You
We have closed our executive session let the record show there was no action taken
Is there a motion to reconvene the public meeting move to reconvene second motion for mr
Little second from mr. Cling all in favor, please indicate
Any pose the public meeting is reconvened. Is there a motion to approve item 8a?
Motion for mr. Meredith second from mr. Little is there any discussion mr. Mr. Cling
question
Mr. Riley or mr
Troy Riley city attorney. This is your recommendation for the council to pursue correct. Yes, it is. Okay. Thank you
Are there is there any other discussion?
Miss Watkins
All in favor, please indicate any opposed the motion carries thank you all
We move on to public hearings to be held 9a
Is a public hearing in order to hear consider an act upon all objections or protests if any for removal of a public nuisance
At 4704 Cavett Drive Northwest Huntsville, Alabama in consideration of resolution ordering evatement of a nuisance located at the same
property
Mr. Irwin. Oh, yes, mayor battle council members Scott urban Community Development Department
This public hearing is regarding the property located at 4704 Cavett Drive Northwest
The property was in violation of the state public nuisance act regarding junk
Community development issued notice to the property owner and industry parties and the property remains in violation
Community development seeking your authorization to abate this joint public nuisance
The condition of the property is before you on the video screen including photos for when the property was initially determined to be a nuisance
The owners and industry parties were notified to attend the City Council meeting in the council chambers
Where the objections could be heard regarding the abatement of this nuisance?
Thank You mr. Irwin the public hearing on item 9a is now open
Is there anyone here who wishes to address the council regarding this item?
Seeing none we will close the public hearing is there a motion to approve
Motion from miss Watkins second from mr. Little are there any questions from mr. Irwin or any discussion?
Seeing none all in favor, please indicate
And impose the motion carries 9b is a public hearing on authorization unauthorizing the demolition of an unsafe building
constituting a public nuisance located at 4204 Berry Street, Northwest on Salam, Alabama and consideration of a resolution
Pertaining to the same mr. Irwin. Yes, this resolution authorizes the demolition of an unsafe building
Constituting public nuisance located at 4204 Berry Street
Northwest the owners and industry parties were notified of this hearing by certified and first-class mail and
Departments may be present tonight to voice any objections
We have photographs all over the property for your review on the screen an independent contractor inspected this property and determined is not structurally feasible to repair
89 percent loss of the independent assessment of fire damage had and had extensive interior damage
The property is declared unsafe no permits have been issued for repair or demolition
An official notice was sent by certified and first-class mail on July 2nd
Requesting demolition and removal of the structure the owners of the industry parties were notified that tonight would be the time and place
Where objections could be heard again? No actions been taken. So we're seeking your authorization to abate this nuisance
The public hearing on item 9b is now open is there anyone here wishing to comment on this item?
Please come to the microphone if you'll please give us your name and address for the record
my name is George Macklin 42 or 4 Berry Street and
I
Talked to a buyer and I got a buyer that's called body in September the property
Okay, thank you ma'am any other comments no ma'am. Thank you so much for sharing that thank you. Are there any other comments?
Public hearing is now closed. Is there a motion to approve the resolution move to approve motion for mr. Little second from the chair
Is there discussion?
Mr. Irwin there is apparently a buyer for this property for September does that change your recommendation?
No, madam president does not this has been a product we've been working on since December of last year
We are aware of the potential of a sale
So this product this public nuisance will be abated regardless of the sale new owners would be held to the same standard
So if by the time we mobilize it will at least 30 days before we were ready for the demolition
So what would the existing or new owners to get demolished by a voluntary compliance?
Any other questions?
All in favor, please indicate any opposed motion carries madam madam president. Yes, miss Watkins
I don't think everyone heard all the council members that can we do a roll call vote?
Mr. Meredith, all right. Mr. Kling. How do you vote?
Miss Watkins hi and chair votes. I the vote is unanimous
Thank you
We will move to 9c 9c is a public hearing on authorizing demolition of an unsafe building constituting public nuisance located at
3042 Boswell Drive Northwest Huntsville, Alabama and consideration of resolution pertaining to the same
Yes, this resolution again authorized the demolition of an unsafe building
Constituting public nuisance at 3042 Boswell Drive Northwest
The owners and industry parties were notified of this hearing by certified in first-class mail and they may be present to voicing objections
We have photographs of the property for review on the screen an independent contractor inspected this property in term
It was not structurally feasible to repair at 90% loss
The walls have come off the foundation the roof system has failed. So it was beyond an economical
Viability for repair or renovation the property has been declared unsafe
No permits have been issued for repair or demolition and official notice was sent by certified in first-class mail on July 2nd
Requesting demolition the removal of the structure the owners and industry parties were notified to attend this City Council meeting
We objections could be heard. No action has been taken. So we're now requesting the council's authorization to abate this nuisance
Thank you, mr. Erwin the public hearing on item 9c is now open
Is there anyone here wishing to address the council regarding item 9c?
Seeing none the public hearing is now closed. Is there a motion to approve this item move to approve motion for mr
Little second from ms. Watkins. Is there any discussion?
Questions for mr. Erwin. I do have one question. I noticed on the the photos. This was May 19th
I'm that's a little while ago. I'm assuming that nothing has gotten better in the interim. You've had someone check it
Yeah, he was checked as most recent this afternoon. So there have been no changes
Something original photos. Okay, all in favor, please indicate. I I any opposed motion carries. Thank you
9d is a public hearing on authorizing community development to assess the cost for the cleanup of public nuisances
Located at certain properties in Huntsville, Alabama and consideration of a resolution pertaining to the same
Yes, ma'am president
This is a public hearing on a resolution authorizing community development to assess the cost for the cleanup of junk public nuisances
Located 3607 Princess Street and 4906 clarity Road Northwest
The resolution before you authorizes an assessment two assessments in total amount of
6,752 dollars and 94 cents all precision requirements relate to the declaration and cleanup of public nuisances have been fulfilled in accordance with the state of Alabama
Public nuisance act property owners were notified that an assessment may be authorized and placed upon their property at this City Council meeting
In which they will have the opportunity to appear and present any objections to the assessed cost
Thank you, is there anyone here wishing to comment or the public hearing is now open for item 9d
Is there anyone here wishing to comment on this item?
Seeing none the public hearing is closed. Is there a motion to approve this resolution motion for mr
Little second from the chair does anyone have questions or comments all in favor, please indicate
I I can you pose the motion carries. Thank you council members. Thank you. Mr
Erwin 9e is a public hearing on authorizing the finance director
To issue a taxi license to shasha Potscoe Jennings doing business as Jennings local
Transport for the operation of three taxis and consideration of a resolution pertaining to the same
Miss Bryant good evening Keisha Bryant director of parking and public transit
This item is a public hearing to authorize our finance director to issue a taxi
License to mr. Jennings doing business as Jennings local transport
He plans to operate three taxis under this business license
He has completed his application and passed his background check and also paid the fee for the license
And so he is due to proceed
Thank You miss Bryant the public hearing on item 9e is now open. Is there anyone here who wishes to comment?
Seeing none the public hearing is closed. Is there a motion to approve the resolution motion from mr
Lil second from mr. Kling any comments mr. Meredith
Miss Bryant
This is specifically for three taxis if he wanted to add additional taxis
Does that have to come before the counselor is that just added? No, so a taxi company requires three at the minimum
So anything above the three he would not have to come to counsel
But he would have to bring the vehicle to our office for inspection metering and tagging
Thank you very much any other questions all in favor, please indicate any pose the motion carry
Thank you. Thank you
9f is a public hearing on the zoning of
24.67 acres of land lying on the north side of University Drive east of Providence Main Street to highway business C4 district and consideration of an ordinance
Pertaining to the same mr. Nunez. Good evening council members
Madam president Thomas Nunez manager of planning and zoning services
This item is located north side of University Drive in east of Providence Main Street
This property was recently annexed into city of Huntsville
Petitioners are seeking to zone the property highway business C4 for commercial retail and hospitality development
Thank You mr. Thomas is there anyone here who we oh, I'm sorry public hearing is now open for item
9f is there anyone who wishes to comment on this item?
Seeing none the public hearing is closed is there a motion to approve motion for mr. Meredith second from mr. Little any discussion
All in favor, please indicate any opposed motion carries
9g is a public hearing on the zoning of 1.98 acres of land
Lying on the north side of Capshaw Road west of Waltrana Highway to neighborhood business C1 district and consideration of an ordinance pertaining to the same
Mr. Nunez councilman this item is located north side of Capshaw Road and west of Waltrana Highway
Petitioners are seeking to zone the property neighborhood business C1 district for property
It was recently annexed into city of Huntsville the proposal here for commercial retail and office development
Thank you is there the public hearing on 9g is now open is there anyone here who wishes to comment on item 9g
Seeing none the public hearing is closed is there a motion to approve motion from mr. Meredith second from mr. Little any discussion
All in favor, please indicate any opposed motion carries
9h is a public hearing on the rezoning of 12.5 acres of land lying on the east side of Lehman Ferry
Road and north of Phil Dots Drive from commercial recreation C5 district to highway business C4 district and consideration of an ordinance pertaining to the same
Mr. Nunez council members
This is a rezoning request city imposed rezoning request for the east side of Linnie Lehman Ferry
Road and north of Phil Dots Drive from commercial recreation C5 district to highway business C4 district
The property in question is actually of Joe Davis Stadium in the Wicks Family Field
However, this will rezone the area in question to highway business C4
Which will bring it up to the proper boundaries of the primary improper boundaries of John Hunt Park
Yeah for the official John Hurt Park portion
The public hearing on item 9h is now open is there anyone who wishes to comment
Seeing none the public hearing is closed. Is there a motion to approve
Motion for mr. Little second for mr. Meredith. Are there any questions or comments?
All in favor, please indicate any opposed the motion carries. Thank you council members. Thank you. Mr. Nunez
We have no public hearings to be set
We have no agenda related public comments. So this brings us then to mayor battle mayor's comments
Thank you
madam president and council members
First off we would like to congratulate Columbia High School. They won their football game Saturday night
Quite a few of us were there and it was a it was a great
It was a great matchup
They went down 14 to nothing in the first first two times that Greensboro got the ball
They went down 14 nothing then they fought back and they ended up winning 41 14
So it was a great game and and it broke a hundred and one game losing streak. So
we're
Congratulations to Columbia and I think you'll something you'll see some other activities happening
Over the next couple weeks for that high school
This weekend Sanford, it's going to play you and a Saturday at
At Joe Davis Stadium Wicks Field
Should be a great game a lot of fun
And please come out and join it. We'll be there and
Watching football at its best as we see Sanford play in you and a and also
Saturday the 10th anniversary of Rocksteady boxing
This is a program that was put in place at John Hunt Park for folks with Parkinson's is a
Rehabilitation process process for those with Parkinson's and they'll be having their 10th anniversary
Believe it's about 10 o'clock on Saturday there
And also this week I had the opportunity to go out on the arsenal to the ribbon cutting for the defense intelligent agencies
material explode exploitation
Facility which is a huge facility
The people out there are to be congratulated for the work that they've done year after year
they keep our country safe and
finally on a sad note
we
memorialize
the signage out on highway 72
east
for
Billy clarity the third he was one of our police officers one of our finest
Who was killed in the line of action?
and
This sign will stay in a memorial fashion for Billy clarity
To for people to remember his sacrifice and what he did for our city
Many many many years ago, so thank you
Thank You mayor battle we will move on to item 13 councilmember comments and we will hear first from councilmember Michelle Watkins no comments
We will move on to councilmember Bill Kling
Well, thank you madam president
But first of all, let me just say on a personal note
Thank you to everyone within the district who came out to vote and especially thank you to
All those folks who voted to reelect me. I felt like
It was a long hot summer. There were some ups
There were some downs, but I enjoyed the process of getting out into the neighborhoods perhaps even more than I normally do
It's a learning process for me and I've heard some issues some concerns that people expressed I think there are things we can do
Talking about how we appear can do our job a little bit better
So I'm going to be looking at things that I can suggest we could work on
To the council as a body to interact better with the public again. We have a great community
we're all on the same team and we just went through a great process that I
Think a lot of people and a lot of countries would like to have the option
I am going to as I said continue my monthly town meetings, of course and
Give me a few days to kind of get my legs back probably Monday or Tuesday of next week
I'll be back doing my little street patrols that I do and I think I got one mayor and four councilmembers
Love it because it gets me away from City Hall. And again, I'm working out of the neighborhoods
We've got great department heads and we work to get whatever needed city maintenance we can take care of so that
action will be continued and certainly I'll be a very strong booster for the
Upcoming I-565 at Memorial Parkway interchange and also as we chase and continued the
Acceleration of the ring road around the city right out road coming into
Alabama Highway
255 now we're up to the northern bypass and from there eventually Hampton Cove and then coming around
Just east of the arsenal that ring road again
I think will take a lot off of the stress of the central portion of the city
And I think that's a great thing for our future as far as quality of life
Again stepping back. We have a great city
We've seen that by the way we've been recognized by around the country
We have challenges of course, but again we I do have many good things and we can be appreciative of that
so again, I'm looking forward to the next four years and
I think there are many great things that are going to be taking place and on one sad note
this week we need to
recognize the passing of Libby Jones who
Had been the wife of Ray Jones who I think people throughout the community knew very wonderful
very smiling beautiful woman who
Was brought a cheer to everyone that she came in contact with and she will be greatly missed
Thank you. Thank you. Mr. Cling will now hear from councilmember David little
Thank You madam president, I just want to give quick shout outs to our transit team
Police engineering public works planning and home utilities for being responsive to citizen needs over the last few weeks as always
I'm grateful as our citizens. Thank you
Thank You, mr. Little will now hear from councilmember John Merida I
want to start by
Wishing a very happy anniversary to the best wife anybody could possibly imagine having
She knows who she is
The mayor stole my thunder, but how about those Columbia High School football players
Wonderful group and just for the record they are currently undefeated
Want to also mention that I plan on having that forum on flock cameras here in council chambers on
September 16th, it'll be at 4 o'clock. And of course as always the public is invited to come talk to the
Issue area experts, which is HPD name act and other law enforcement folks and
Again the public is cordially invited to be here hear what they have to say but also have the opportunity to question them
want to thank
Columbia High School and the folks at the central office of
HCS for inviting me on a sneak peek of the junior ROTC building there at Columbia
it is a
fantastic state-of-the-art building that I know they are looking forward to
getting into and also making available to all of the
ROTC programs within HCS schools
Looking forward to the Brown
Groundbreaking at Westmore Landing which will be on Monday August 23rd at 1 p.m
Been looking forward to this project for quite a while
It is going to bring that Providence style living to Limestone County
And then finally, I want to thank the Chamber of Commerce and the research Park Board for inviting me
along with my district 5
Representative counterpart for the Huntsville City Schools Carlos Matthews to present medals at the UCI
Paracycling World Championships on Saturday, September 5th. Thank you. Thank you, Mr. Merida and
I will extend my congratulations to Mr.
Kling and Mr. Little for their reelection to counsel to Holly McCarty for reelection to the school board and
Peyton Redfern who is newly elected to the school board as well and thank all of those who offered themselves for public service in this municipal
election
We'll go on to item 14 the Finance Committee report 14a is a resolution authorizing expenditures for payment is their motion to approve
I'm I move for authorization and approval of expenditures in the amount of
53 million six hundred seventeen thousand four hundred fourteen dollars and
27 cents
Second mr. Little will take the second
Any discussion on this? I do have one question. The number is unusually large
Miss Smith, would you like to?
Offer a quick explanation to the public certainly
I'll be happy to penny Smith director of finance within these numbers are two actually very large
Payments one is for our school system. So as you are well aware the school is
Is moving through their capital plan and so they present to us some
Payments for for that out of the debt that we have issued and so for the school system
and so those payments came to
14 14 million four hundred thousand and and change and then we had another payment that a couple of a
couple of months ago
the City Council passed resolution 26 for
14 purchasing the assets purchasing the food and beverages assets that were owned
but by
by the
Huntsville venue group and so that has that it took a while to get all the inventory
Counted and make sure that all those numbers were correct
So that payment actually went through on this particular item as well
And so between those two payments if you back those out will back down to about
27.7 million
Any other questions or comments all in favor, please indicate any opposed motion carries
15 if this is board appointments to be voted on we have several 15 a is a resolution to reappoint Thornton Stanley jr
To the board of examinations and appeals for construction industries place eight his current seat for a three-year term to expire September 21
2029 is their motion to
Motion from mr. Cling second from mr. Little all in favor, please indicate
Any opposed the motion carries
15b is a resolution to reappoint Dennis Dean to the board of examinations and appeals for construction industries place to his current seat for a
Three-year term to expire September 21
2029 motion for mr. Little
Second second for mr. Cling all in favor, please. Yes, sir
You might want to specify you didn't on the last one, but it requires four fifths for passage, right?
All in favor, please indicate
Any opposed the motion carries
15c is a resolution to reappoint Heather Bender to the Animal Services Advisory Committee place to her current seat for a three-year term to expire
September 8 2029 is their motion motion to motion from mr. Mayor second second for mr. Little all in favor
Please indicate any opposed the motion carries
15cd is a resolution to reappoint Colin Keller to the Animal Services Advisory Committee place five is current seat for a three-year term to expire
September 8 2029 is their motion
Motion for mr. Little second from mr. Cling all in favor, please indicate any opposed the motion carries
15e is a resolution to reappoint Christopher Jason Smith to the board of examinations and appeals for construction industries place 16 is current seat for a
Three-year term to expire September 21 2029 is their motion to approve
Motion for mr. Little second from the chair all in favor, please indicate
The motion carries
15f is a resolution to appoint Joshua Pennington to the Huntsville Police Citizens Advisory Council place 13 due to the resignation of Brian Webb
For the remainder of a vacant four-year term to expire August 21 2027 motion to motion from mr.
Meredith second second from mr. Little all in favor, please indicate. I any opposed the motion carries
15g is a resolution to appoint Larry Durham to the board of examinations and appeals for construction industries place 7 to the seat
Previously held by Russ Grimes for a three-year term to expire September 21 2029 chair makes the motion
Second for mr. Little all in favor, please indicate. I I in opposed any opposed the motion carries. I think mr. Durham is here
Thank you for your service
We have no board appointment nominations on the agenda are there any nominations from the floor
Then we'll go on item 17 Huntsville utilities items. Mr. Gertriss. Do you have a report for us?
Thank You council president just Joe Gertriss. I will almost call myself Joseph
I never do that Joe Gertriss Huntsville utilities and as promised we're just here to answer any questions
You may have nothing to report tonight
We will appear at your next meeting with our FY 27 budget. Thank you, sir
We appreciate you being here of 18 legal department item transactions
18a is an ordinance authorizing the vacation of two portions of a utility and drainage easement track one Richland Park second edition
containing point zero seven and point and
Zero point. Let me do that again zero point zero seven and zero point eleven
Acres is there a motion to approve move to approve motion for mr. Little second from the chair any questions all in favor
Please indicate any opposed motion carries
18b is a resolution authorizing the acceptance of a zero point five to eight acre tract of land from North Valley land
LLC for a sanitary sewer easement off of highway 53 at Blake Bottom Road
Is there a motion to approve motion for mr. Little second from the chair all in favor, please indicate
Any opposed the motion carries this brings us to unfinished business items for action
19a is an ordinance to declare certain real property located at the intersection of Moore's Mill Road and vintage drive a surplus and
Authorized mayor to enter into a purchase and sale agreement between the city of Huntsville and opid an
Incorporated is there a motion motion for mr. Little second from the chair. Mr. Davis is here with us to make a presentation
Presentation
Thank You madam president. Good evening council member Shane Davis director urban economic development. So
Council members from time to time probably six or seven times a year. We bring you real estate contracts before this council
In various forms sometimes are industrial development. Sometimes are retail development
Sometimes their property that may be a counter agency that we're helping and tonight is one of those
Ordinances and when we do that there's two-step process. That's why it's an ordinance
So we must declare it surplus no longer needed for public use and then in our purchase and sale agreement
So that's what you're going to vote on here momentarily
So I want to give a little bit of history about this property about this property and how the city
Came to acquisition of it. So it's located in Chase Industrial Park
The property is located front in Moore's Mill Road and was the former campus of Qualitas
Pharmaceutical, I think locally a lot of people refer to it as prop's pharmaceutical
The city acquired the undeveloped portion of this back in about 2010 after the acquisition of Qualitas pharmaceuticals by
endopharmaceutical
The prop's family donated this land to the sea the undeveloped portion
In the direction that it had three purposes for which us to dispose of it one a public use or
Commercial or industrial development they wanted to see good happen out of it for the betterment of the community
So on this screen what I wanted to point out is
The the pharmaceutical campus that you see kind of central to it with the ring road
Those buildings are still active actually trial or X pharmaceuticals is in the southernmost building still in operation
The building to the east is is Lidos one of our defense contractors in our city with multiple locations and the building to
The north is more warehouse logistics storage
I do want to point out that the dash yellow area was part of that original
Acquisition by the city and a couple years ago. We in
Partnership with some property that allowed us to expand in John Hunt Park
This council approved a development agreement and real estate agreement with Alabama National Guard
For this to become one of their latest training centers if you've been by there that project is getting very near completion
Completion it looks very nice very nice
I do want to point out to the north and to the east of the Lidos building
That area has been reserved for the future northern bypass to connect to US highway 72
So that is the corridor being reserved for that as it would cross Winchester Road, Marshall Road and come back to US
231 so that leaves the
Southernmost portion and that's what we're presenting to you tonight
So what's before you is a 15 acre site as you see
Hatched out here the southernmost portion of the city property purchase price is
One point one two six million dollars that is seventy five thousand dollars an acre if you're doing the math
That is in conducive of the market rate for this area of chase industrial park in this highway 72 area
As we do with any real estate contract
We want to make sure that the reason that you would vote to sell that that project gets delivered to the community should it not
There's a repurchase option
So that's pretty standard in our contracts. You always see those so there's 18 month purchase a
obligation should the project not move forward the city has the right to
Regain the property at the same purchase process. There's no escalation that we'd pay more to receive that property back
So the proposed land use so this property due to the utilities both public and private utilities in this area
We felt that this is good for the overall community the proposed use is a regional fiber networks switch facility. So that's a big word, right?
What I wanted to describe to you in the public what that really means is to get more efficient in delivering high-speed long-distance
reliable transmission in
routing of existing fiber internet service in our data that we send every day whether that's email storing
social media or just conducting business I like to
Edequate that to what the ATT building just outside this
Building we set tonight across the street here is to our phone network
That building is a hub to distribute
Incoming and outgoing play in line phone service that building stretches and provides service all the way in in southern, Tennessee
So think of this and very similar to that but for our existing fiber infrastructure through our city
There's additional benefits to the city so the southernmost portion you see in red we are retaining and
John Hamilton and the fire department in looking at long-range plans has identified this with the rapid growing area of East Huntsville
Is a perfect location for a future fire station
So in working with the purchaser in the layout of how they would build their facility
Connect to the fiber network and provide this better efficiency and more high-speed service throughout the region
They've agreed in their layout to build a new road for which our fire station would gain access to
there so
That would be at no cost to the city
And the proceeds from this should you approve this tonight?
The administration would like to take those proceeds put them in the 1990 plan to help fund this project
Council members off it. It's it's not a lot. It's not very complicated
Open any questions you may have council members any questions for mr. Davis mr. Meredith
My question is just how many acres are going to be utilized for the fire station?
So if if you look, you know, it's once they get in design
There's much more property here than is needed for the initial
but we wanted to carve enough out to as the city grows if if
You know fire department need a new ladder truck bay like we're doing out in Greenbrier
That there's room to expand so
The typical initial is two to three maybe five acres at most if you look here
There's a just under ten acres of additional property for the city to use. Thank you, sir. You're welcome
Any other questions for mr. Davis?
All in favor, please indicate any opposed the motion carries. Thank you. Mr. Davis. Thank you council members
This brings us to 20 new items
Business items for consideration or action
Are there any I to these items will be approved in one motion unless any member of the council wishes to remove an item for
Discussion the reading of each item will be waived unless a council member requests. Otherwise, are there any items?
Anyone wishes to hold separately mr. Meredith?
Item M
That's all okay miss Watkins a
B C
I
P Q S
S or X S isn't Sam
Okay item a
We see I
Am
Yes, as in Sam and chair moves for consolidation approval of items 20 D
To H 20 J
20 J K and L
20 N and O
20 are
20 T and 20 you
Second second for mr. Little all in favor, please indicate I'd opposed those items are approved
We will now move on to 28 20 a is a resolution authorizing travel expenses. Is there a motion?
Motion for mr. Little second from the chair is there discussion
council members any questions
Yes, miss Smith, did you get a chance to send me the the updated this for this
Parts of the approval not for for this it's it's in
No, I did not realize that you wanted them for every session, okay
Okay, I will send those thank you
Any other questions all in favor, please indicate
I
Any opposed the motion carries 20 B is an ordinance amending budget ordinance number 25-744
By changing appropriate funding for various departments and funds is their motion
Motion for mr. Little second from the chair
Questions or comments for discussion
Miss Watkins you held this do you have idea I want her to explain for the listening public
So this this item has been donated so we have a
we have a
fire pole
That that should so this is for a budgeted item and sorry not donation budgeted item that increases a
transfer to our 1990 capital projects fund from
From our fire and rescue department so that that
Contract and everything will be executed within the capital projects funds
Along with the with the remainder of things around it
And so if this is literally just moving money from from the general fund where we initially
Establish that to the capital projects fund so that the money can be properly expended according to the contract
Thank you any other comments or questions all in favor, please indicate
I
Opposed the motion carries 20 C is a resolution authorizing the mayor
To take a portion of the proceeds of certain future borrowing is to reimburse the 2014 capital improvement fund of the city for expenditures incurred
Prior to borrowing issuance is there a motion to approve motion for mr. Little second from the chair
Miss
Miss Smith, can you help us understand what we're doing here? Oh good evening penny Smith director of finance
This is you've seen these types of resolutions come before you
It is a tool that we use in order to in order to right-size
Any borrowing that we do moving forward as we go forward?
So so there's been a tip a tiff that has been set in place
along with a 1% lodging tax that has been set in place to fund the
The bomb on Civic Center expansion and
And so there will be borrowings up to 260 million dollars
Obviously that is an that is a max amount
That is not the actual borrowings themselves there will be multiple series of borrowings as we move through this three-year project and
And so setting that in place there are a number of things that are starting to occur and happen
And as we move across that we want to be able to capture that into the borrowings right now the first borrowing set
Maybe for spring February March timeframe. We're not sure of the size or scope of that borrowing as of yet
any discussion
All in favor, please indicate I pose the motion carries
20i is a resolution authorizing the mayor to enter an agreement between the city of Huntsville and three-notch group ink for engineering design services
For Alabama Highway 53 and Douglas Road intersection improvements project number 71-26-SP
56 is there a motion to approve?
motion for mr. Little
second by the chair
Miss Martin. Yes. Good evening Kathy Martin director of City Engineering
So this is a design contract with three-notch group
It's for intersection improvements at the Alabama Highway 53 and Douglas Road
And what we're doing is adding a right turn lane at Douglas Road to minimize congestion in the area
So this is a lump-sum design contract amount of forty five thousand ninety dollars. Thank you questions or comments
Do you know when this construction is going to start?
We would hope by spring of next year. We've got to go through our dot permitting process
Okay, thank you. Miss Martin
Any other questions or comments all in favor, please indicate. I hope the motion carries
20m is a resolution authorizing the city attorney to settle a personal injury crime of Alicia Smith
Is there a motion to approve motion for mr. Little second from the chair?
Mr. Riley would it be appropriate for us to discuss this or should we go into another executive session?
We should if we want to discuss it we need to go in the executive council members. Is there a motion for executive session?
motion to go into executive session
second
Mr. Meredith, how do you vote?
To go into executive session. I mr. Kling. How do you vote?
Mr. Kling, I'm thinking come back to me would you
Mr. Little hi mr. Watkins. Hi
Chair votes. I we will be going into executive. We will now convene for executive session
Yes, sir. I guess a personal contact a comment
I would have on this it seems like something like this an individual council member can consult with the city attorney before the meeting but all
Went along with it as a courtesy
We will now convene for close
Suspend the public meeting and we will go into executive session. We hope to return
I would think this should not take longer than ten minutes or so
You
Being the public meeting motion for mr. Kling
Mr. Little all in favor, please indicate motion. The meeting is now convened. We have a motion on the floor to approve
item 20m
All in favor, please indicate. I post the motion. Caution carries
20p is a resolution authorized the mayor to submit a grant application of the Federal Transit Authority
Administration FTA for the FY 27 formula grant their motion to approve
Motion from mr. Kling second from mr. Little any discussion conversation questions
it is
Yeah, is there gonna be public input on?
How all this money gets used when you get further down the line miss Bryant? Yes, Keisha Bryant director of parking and public transit
So these are our annual dollars that are appropriated from FTA and so we will use them for our operations cost
Which are covered by these federal dollars at a 50% rate and then we'll also use them for a capital cost at a rate of 80%
For the federal dollars and so we will not have any public hearings. We are just continuing our operations
There's nothing new that's going on with these dollars
It's just so that we can access and allocate the dollars that the federal government has allocated to us
Any other questions
This blockings well, no, mr. Kling jumped in before I could ask question even though I held the item, but thank you miss
read your mind
Thank you. Mr. Meredith. No, I've got something else. Let's finish this off and then okay all in favor, please indicate
I opposed motion carries if I can interrupt. Yes, just for the record. Mr. Riley. Could you for?
Compliance with the opens a meeting act give the reason for the last
Need for executive session. Yes, and I apologize for failing to do that. I kind of got a call-off prize there, but yes
Once again, I am an attorney in the in the
license to practice in Alabama and in my judgment this falls within the open
litigation and discussing with your attorney those litigation issues
Attorney those litigation matters that need to be done in confidence. So it does apply to one of the the
the
exceptions in the open meeting act that allows for executive session for the record could you give the the site citation
Citation of the code. Yes
Just for the record
It's a
3625 a dash 7 a
Thoroughly. Thank you, sir. Thank you, madam president
Thank you, mr. Meredith
20 Pete 20 Q is a resolution authorizing mayor to enter into facility use agreement between the city of Huntsville and Foxtrot company
LLC is there a motion to motion for mr. Little second from the chair
Members John Hamilton city administrator so customers the the item before you is
Our standard facility use agreement that you see each year for the fair carnival event that occurs down at John Hunt Park
This event is scheduled from September 24th to the 27th
Any questions for mr. Hamilton?
Thank You, mr. Hamilton. That's what I wanted to know. Well, mr. Rock City Fair. Thank you
Any other questions all in favor, please indicate. I heard the motion carries and
Finally 20s 20s is resolution authorized mayor to enter into memorandum of understanding between the Federal Bureau of Investigation
The Huntsville City Board of Education and the city of Huntsville public department police department to formally establish the Tennessee Valley threat assessment and threat
Management team is there a motion motion for mr. Little second from the chair
Chief Giles, can you share with us the action being taken requested here? Yes, ma'am
This is a mo you with FBI in respects to
Basically just violent acid initially
When law enforcement traditionally are dealing with if we deal with this after the fact in other words once the incident had already occurred
What they discovered back in 2015 to a symposium was the best way to tackle this on a multidisciplinary team
Was to do that assessment and then threat management
so what this do they were asking us to be a host agency the FBI and
We are going to collaborate with the school city schools because that's where we're obviously the concern is throughout the neighborhood
But especially with the schools and at this point in time we can help identify threats ahead of time and then but once we get through that
We'll be able to partner with other local resources such as mental health to provide
Resources for the individual and this can go outside the schools as well. In other words, it can go in a normal business world as well
Any questions for Chief Giles?
Chief Giles, will this assessment take place in one of the schools?
Not necessary. It's gonna depend on the circumstances
When we set up a multidisciplinary team, it'll bring us all together
Within that group and we'll discuss it. It's not knowing which cases we'll be dealing with at the time
It's hard to say but we will be pulling the schools in. So like an exercise?
Yes, they'll be involved if it involves a student. They would definitely be involved. Okay. Thank you
Any other comments or questions?
All in favor, please indicate I oppose the motion carries. We have no new business that concludes our business before us this evening
We have no new business items for introduction. The next item on our agenda is second roster public comments
We have several signed up. So I would suggest that we take a 10-minute break and we will reconvene at 718
You
Right, we will call the meeting back to order
So we are now at second roster public comments
This portion of the meeting is reserved for persons wishing to address the Council on matters relating to city business
Whether or not such items are on the meeting agenda those wishing to comment have signed up in advance
When called approach the microphone state your name home address and city of residence and I will also call the person
Following so that you can be ready to come up. We'll move this process along
Each speaker speaker may address the council for three minutes speakers shall refrain from entering into a dialogue with council members or city staff
And from making comments regarding the good name and character of any individual
The first person signed up to speak is Christopher Boulware who will be followed by Maggie Minsk
Mr. Boulware will just come right here and you will have each have three minutes
Good evening City Council, I am an Alabama native who graduated high school and college here name an address for the record
Please Christopher Boulware 1 1 9 Rebecca pines Drive, Madison, Alabama. Thank you
I've lived in five states across this country. I've seen enough to know that Huntsville is a special place
and one worth preserving
That's why I'm here to address what I consider a travesty against American freedoms
AI powered automated license plate readers with flock safety as the infamous market leader
marketed to eliminate crime
This technology is drag net surveillance paving the road to a surveillance state
Alabama now ranks six nationally and these cameras per capita
Flock claims that it makes community safer, but a leaked internal tool called OS investigate
Showed these systems can correlate plate scans with data broker information
Social security numbers phone numbers relatives
Performing what flock itself calls a one command background check
Another tool convoy analysis flags vehicles traveling together letting police monitor
Who regularly gathers whether a criminal ring or simply neighbors co-workers or protesters?
With 20 billion scans per month you'd assume that flock protects the data and it's wrong
Researchers gained route access to a camera in under 30 seconds with the latter
credentials transmit and clear text and the cameras violate eight of ten industry internet security standards
Flock doesn't even require multi-factor authentication and flock logins have been found for sale on
Russian cybercrime forums and the public is responding at least 54 cities have canceled their flock contracts in 26 alone
Including the LAPD after an audit showed a one in three chance of pulling over an innocent person
The opposition is bipartisan
Governor DeSantis recently said that the cameras are out of control Congress from Birchett from Tennessee
Introduced HR 9800 to cut federal funding and make no mistake
Protecting Americans from AI overreach and mass surveillance has become one of the biggest issues
Voters use as their North Star at the ballot box
For Huntsville, this is a national security issue
We are one of the largest defense hubs in the nation and foreign adversaries can buy stolen login credentials for a few hundred dollars
Map the vehicles of our defense contractors trace them home and profile cleared personnel for blackmail in minutes with no warrant
Our founders warned us James Madison said there are more instances of the abridgment of the freedom of people by gradual and silent encroachments
By those in power and then by violent and sudden usurpations and Benjamin Franklin said those who would give up essential liberty to purchase a little
temporary safety
Deserve neither liberty or safety the ISIS council to cancel flocks contract and pass a local ordinance requiring
warrants for any mass surveillance data
Thank you. Thank you, sir
Next person to speak is Maggie men Minsk following miss Minsk. We will hear from Jerry Burnett
Hi, my name is Maggie Minsk and I live in Madison
But I'm also a business owner in Huntsville's district five
I am a single mother and business owner and I am also concerned about flock safety
Which I believe is rather Orwellian in speech and might be more aptly named flock surveillance
I am truly concerned
The cameras take videos essentially a warrantless search of everyone in Huntsville, Madison Decatur, etc. All have contracts with flock
Huntsville did it first Madison got theirs
Not too long ago for 86,000 the North Alabama multi-agency Crime Center uses license plate readers cameras
Gunshot detection which is microphones and also intelligence AI
However, statistically it seems like a study of flock cameras showed that ALPRs
Are wrong 71% of the time leaving us to pay for a lawyer and check off work and prove in court that it wasn't us
So there's a concern about
Innocence until proven guilty and once the data is released
It becomes a cybersecurity target
In January flock confirmed a security incident involving its condor cameras that exposed live
Camera feeds and archival footage and allowed video to be deleted
Researchers have also demonstrated vulnerabilities in ALPR technology that exposed these surveillance systems to unauthorized access
Anything connected to a network has been exposed to a network of unauthorized access
Unauthorized access anything connected to a network is potentially vulnerable
Two days ago August 25th, Pflugerville, Texas unanimously voted to end its plot contract after it was revealed that
1.6 million searches had been conducted by
459 outside
organizations within a six-month period
This week a US Senate Judiciary Subcommittee opened a formal investigation into flocks data collection access and sharing practices
Floxone materials acknowledge that its LPR system is connected across 49 states while the ALC
ACLU has raised concerned about the creation of a nationwide surveillance
infrastructure as a mental health professional
I'm concerned about the privacy and safety of clients or any vulnerable marginalized residents
How do we protect those seeking refuge from domestic violence stalking and other dangerous situations?
Anyone can gain access and reconstruct where a client what a client lives or a police officer judge
City council member track the movements of someone with national top-secret clearance and what happens when Huntsville's military?
Intelligence aerospace and and defense activity becomes part of a searchable
hackable
surveillance database
The overall infrastructure also has an environmental cost yet to be ascertained
Finally taxpayers, thank you very much miss Minsk. Your time is up. Thank you for joining us tonight
We'll now hear from Jerry Burnett. Mr. Burnett will be followed by Austin Jones
Jerry Burnett 2405 Green Hill Drive
To the mail thank you president and the rest of the council
Good evening. Thank you for allowing me to speak
I'm here because I have an issue with my next door neighbor
Who doesn't seem to care to keep their property up?
and I've had to call
my councilwoman
several times about the
Trash and debris that they leave around the house. They don't care to
Bring the trash can in
The
Drop trash trash on the ground. They don't they'll just walk right over it
they don't mind drinking a soda throw the can out the door and
From time to time I've had to pick trash up
That's coming over into my yard after laid out for several days and wind blow it into the yard
And I told my wife I said well, maybe we can put up with it until we can find a relocate
but then they got a cat the cat that continues to
do use my
Property for its bathroom
So I spent a lot of money to make my backyard cat cat proof
well, then the cat start going in the front to use, you know, and it's creating flies and other
insects and I've called the
animal control and they come by a couple of times and
Once I come out to talk to them because I wanted to make sure you get your get them to clean their
Cat litter out my yard and
Co. C told me says uh, why don't you go back in the house, sir?
I got this but in the meantime cat started doing this thing. So I'm
I don't like picking up cat litter, but that's why I don't have a cat
And I think if it's the owner should be responsible for their own
cats and as it turned out the
animal control said it all
If you get a picture of it
And and go to the city magistrate and then maybe you can get some
Satisfaction from that so we'll give that a try put
Video up and I captured a cat out on my property and then we go to the city
Magistrate and she looks at it and she says well the animal control said a cat is y'all. This is a great cat
I said, well, I don't know where y'all a cat come from then she said well you got to do it all over again
So it looked like I'm getting the run around and in the meantime, I got a cat problem
That's my issue I wonder what is there any solution to
Thank thank you, sir
We can certainly get someone to meet miss miss Watkins will meet with you afterwards to discuss it
Thank you very much. We'll next hear from Austin Jones who will be followed by code and help our Kayden Helbling
Hi there, I'm Austin Jones
Dress on the sheet and I'm out. No one's crossroads
I'm a 21 year army vet and a member of the Democratic Socialists of America and I'm running for Madison County School Board district 3
I'm here to talk about safety
The top three causes of death for children according to a New England Journal of Medicine study published May 13th
2026 are
firearms
motor vehicles and poison
Followed closely by cancer which is on the rise among children
But there is something more insidious not captured by this study
poverty and
Poverty has lifelong effects on our children our future
the poverty rate for children in Madison County is
42.5%
That means just about every other child you meet around is living in poverty in the richest
country in the history of the world
This doesn't count the number of kids that are borderline impoverished which I would bet puts that number well over 50%
What are we doing?
What's going on? I?
Constantly hear from the Republicans how important and how much they care for kids
Do you really think the Epstein class sitting in office care?
My dad always said the proof is in the pudding well the children ain't even got no pudding to eat
And what they do eat?
60% of it is processed
Why are we living in a real-life Hunger Games?
That book is a warning not a goal on how society is supposed to run
The parents of these children are working their tails off
Overtime two and three jobs with what to show for it on top of the Epstein class not paying people they steal
50 billion a year in wages, so what are we doing?
What's going on?
Freedom starts with education, but it sure is hard to study when you're hungry and your parents can't cook because they are at work
Freedom starts with education
All the power to all the people free Palestine solidarity forever
Thank you, mr. Jones we'll hear now from kaden helbling. Mr. Helbling will be followed by gerald vines
I'm kaden helbling from huntsville. My address is on the sheet
I wanted to follow up with the city council and make others in huntsville aware of the status of my records request
Surrounding the flock audit logs with the city. I spent eight months requesting those audit logs
That the city is legally required to have for oversight that they are capable providing electronically and have been provided by blount county in alabama
Unredacted for the public to review but for whatever reason the city has determined that they are not legally compelled to provide them
After my last update at city council during the last city council meeting
I stayed after to speak with council president
Robinson about why blunt county under the same rules and regulations
As huntsville was able to provide the same documents I was asking for
And she told me that it is because huntsville is bigger and has more lawyers
That is something that I think those living in district three should keep in mind during the runoff election on september 22nd
Additionally city attorney trey reilly told me that I will have to go to court if I want these audits and that I should
And should I be successful that I will be putting children in danger
One more thing that I would like to highlight because there is news of flock implementing some new safety guidelines
The city's official stance is as follows
The city rejects the premise that flock safety's guidance documents establish the city's legal obligations under alabama law
Flock safety is a private software vendor its publications user manuals customer guidance documents and recommended practices
Are not statutes judicial decisions or opinions of the alabama attorney general
They possess no president and no presidential value and cannot define expand or restrict the city's legal obligations
Under alabama's public records act or any alabama case law that has endeavored to interpret the same
Nor can they be substituted for the statutory analysis required under alabama law
Effectively the city can do whatever it chooses regardless of what flock recommends or suggests that the users do
So if you hear anything about you know flock implementing new safety tools take it with a massive heap of salt
The city does not have to follow it
These systems have never been up for public vote have no means of public oversight
And it appears that rather than listening to those living in huntsville and change those things
The city is looking at other vendors with all the same problems. Let's do better
Thank you
Thank you. We'll now hear from gerald vines who will be followed by molly cluck
Good evening gerald vines 165 mead park drive meridians alabama. Thank you
Good evening mayor
Madam president and council members. Thank you for allowing me to share this vision with for the omega sci-fi fraternities 50th
state meeting
Hosted here in iraq city october the second through the fourth. I am the state marshal for this meeting. We're excited to
Be in huntsville for this meeting
Represent and it is represented more than more than just a gathering of men
It is an opportunity to provide economic impact serve the huntsville community and invest in the next generation through youth enrichment activities
The economic impact we're expecting approximately 1000 members from across the state of alabama beyond
Our attendees will have an opportunity to experience the city's restaurants entertainment and other destinations and support the local economy
We encourage them to stay in our hotels and patronize the local businesses the community impact
however
Our presence in the city of huntsville is not just economic service who is the heart of omega sci-fi
we are planning a community service project with uh the boys and girls club of greater huntsville and the pelasca fight to to
Set up their computer labs for them to
For the educational opportunities community programming and and at the center
As you know access to technology is increasingly important for students pursuing education career opportunities and and and digital skills
We have a talent competition that will be here friday night
October the second at the marriott and this competition will be will be hosted by our fraternity
And we have students from all over the state competing in this competition
Then we have a stem competition will be held on saturday at the um
Space camp operation center now we have members young kids from older state at the same companies as well
Our goal
Is to ensure that when the members of omega sci-fi leave huntsville we leave behind something tangible
That continues to benefit the community
We welcome the city of huntsville to partner with us in making this a memorable and impactful weekend for our members
Our young people and the entire huntsville community as a part of this weekend's activities
Our public meeting will be held on friday october the 7th at 7 pm at the huntsville marriott
We will be honored to have representatives
From the city of huntsville to join us bringing greetings and welcoming our visitors to the to our great city
Your presence and help would help demonstrate the strong partnership between the city of huntsville
And the alabama statewide organization of omega sci-fi fraternity
as we come together
around economic opportunity service
and
The arts and development of our youth we look forward to welcoming you to this and the city to our alabama statewide organization
Meeting will make us our five on october the second through the fourth. Thank you. Thank you. Mr. Vines
We'll now hear from molly cluck who will be followed by louise
balderrama
My name is molly cluck. My address is correct on the form and i'm a resident of huntsville. Thank you
Good evening, everyone. I'm here tonight to demand rejection of the expansion of automatic license plate reader surveillance
This is often presented as a simple public safety tool, but that description leaves out the most important question
What happens to the relationship between citizens and government?
When the government is allowed to collect information on everyone all the time without suspicion of wrongdoing
Alprs collect license plates locations and time stamps from everyone who happens to drive past a camera
That means the government can build a searchable record of where ordinary people have been even when those people are not suspected of committing any crime
That is an inversion of a basic principle of a free society
We are being asked to accept a system where everyone is treated as a potential future suspect
The government collects first and justifies the search later
Instead of public power being limited and accountable ordinary people are made permanently available for inspection
Citizens should not have to live under constant surveillance so that someday the government might decide their past movements are worth investigating
And surveillance does not fall equally on everyone people who work irregular hours rely on older vehicles travel across jurisdictions
Organize with neighbors attend protests visit clinics or move through heavily monitored areas are more likely to be recorded in scrutinizing
A system that collects everyone's movements becomes a system that disciplines the people with the least power to challenge it
And once that infrastructure exists the question is no longer simply whether we trust today's police department
It is whether we trust every future administration every future employee with access
Every agency this data may be shared with and every future expansion of this technology
Power that can be abused finds someone willing to abuse it
We also need to ask whether the evidence justifies the cost
A quasi-randomized study found an increase in vehicle recoveries, but no increase in arrests and little clear evidence of general crime prevention benefits
Early experimental research into northern virginia jurisdictions found no statistically significant reduction in general crime auto-related crime auto theft or theft from autos
associated with alpr patrols
Public resources should be directed towards measures that strengthen people's security directly
Reliable emergency response housing stability mental health services safe transportation and the conditions that allow people to live with dignity
A technology that expands the state's power to watch everyone should not take priority over investments that improve people's lives
A safe society does not require turning the entire public into a database just in case someone might be useful to investigation later
The people of this community are not raw material for an ever-growing surveillance system
Safety and freedom are not opposites
No one here should accept a false choice between protecting our community and protecting our civil liberties
I urge this council to reject the expansion of alpr surveillance and to refuse to build a system of mass
Suspicionless monitoring in our community. Thank you
Thank you. We'll now hear from louise falderama who'll be followed by joice macklin
Is mr. Faldorama here
Good evening mayor and council. Good evening. So I accidentally name an address by so louis falderama 1580 john wesley way. Thank you
So I thought that was a sign-in sheet so I accidentally signed up to speak so while i'm here
Um, I'd like to introduce myself again louis falderama
I am the chair for the city of huntsville's community development citizen advisory council
and while i'm here, I would like to thank community development for everything it does and
I would like to cordially invite everyone on council
We've already had mayor battle come speak to us to join us in any one of our meetings
So that's a standing invitation for whenever we get a chance
um
One thing we have been talking about a lot during the cac is housing affordability here in the city of huntsville
Um as an alabama native i've gotten to see the process of housing skyrocket in my short life that I have been alive
Um a lot of our residents who grew up here are starting to feel the impact of that
So down payments are starting to become incredibly high and we who grew up here and have lived here our whole lives
Are struggling to be able to afford some of those so we ask that if council could
Seek some solutions to help address some of these issues that'd be greatly appreciated. Thank you
Thank you, sir. Thank you for being with us and for serving on the advisory council
We'll now hear from joyce macklin who will be followed by edward
Uh point at tosky jr
Miss macklin
She's not here
We will then go on to mr. Ponytosky
And who will be followed by christopher
Bolware
Edward Ponytosky 821 Mira vista drive welcome. Uh, i'm just here to just as a general citizen provide my um
My
Discrepancy with the flock camera industry as of right now
I don't think that's a good direction for the city of huntsville to move forward and I just wanted to provide my uh,
General comment on that. Thank you. Thank you, sir
We'll now hear from christopher bolware who will be followed by shaylon moody
I signed up
Okay, very good. Thank you shaylon shaylon moody and then dr. Angela somerset
Hi
Thank you mayor and council members for hearing me out on an opportunity to raise the level of safety name and address
Please for the record. Yes. My name is chalene moody
Address is correct on the sheet and your city of residence huntsville alabama. Thank you, sir. Yes, ma'am
So thank you for hearing me out on something of an opportunity to raise the safety awareness level across the city
Um, I am a been a residence, uh resident of huntsville since 2018
Yes, I am another engineer in town
I'm also a civic engagement academy alum and related to
Safety, i'm also former boy scout former volunteer firefighter and also went through the training classes for the community emergency response team
through manson county cert
In a growing city like ours
We have an opportunity to address concerns of many new residents who may not know what to expect when they call 911
Or how best to interact with first responders?
Additionally some some just lack confidence or competence to assess someone in medical distress
Which may cause the situation to worsen
Metrics of growing cities often show safety and harm prevention efforts may fall short
and
Unless you have a critical mass of trained professionals or bystanders
Just generally spread across the city
What I propose then
Is a pilot project for a citizen safety and preparedness academy which could slot right in next to the citizens police academy
And the citizens or the civic engagement academy
The end goal would be to increase survivability rates of victims reported on 911 calls
Related to emergency medical distress through raising the overall safety consciousness of our residents
The situations I have in mind are oftentimes critical
Such as heart attack stroke blunt trauma mental illness episodes seizures
Heat stroke excessive bleeding and similar
Having someone who practices clear communication and risk assessment
In dynamic situations are some of the best people to have in an emergency
Their confidence and commonest is a safety multiplier
A pilot program of about 30 participants seems to be a sizable enough cohort
Which can train in how to speak and interact with the emergency call center personnel and first responders
Trained in CPR and ad and recognizing signs of various medical conditions
Additionally fire extinguisher use and fire escape planning would be helpful
After sessions conclude we can check in quarterly with the participants and the newly safe
Safely aware to see what kind of effect they have had
In the community and continue the program pending the results
Raising the average level of safety consciousness across the city may show up in different ways than increasing the survival rates
Dispatchers and first responders having an easier time to get through an incident
Participants may take up careers in emergency services and we may see an uptick of residents getting formal CPR and first aid training
It might even cause some old boys to formally designate a 911 caller for a pickup game of football. Thank you, sir
We appreciate you being here
We'll now hear from dr. Angela Somerset who will be followed by um, tyler gotney
All right
Good evening council. My name is dr. Angela Somerset and I reside at nine chalkstone street
Thank you, sir. Okay, ma'am
This evening I would like to talk about a double standard
I would also like to talk about the importance of
financial responsibility
The same way that our city requires us to be responsible financially
I would like to also see that our utility company
is responsible
right now young people are facing a huge responsibility as well as a
pressure in regards to affording homes
medical care
But our city sits uniquely under an umbrella for the city of huntsville
Huntsville utility sits under that umbrella as well as huntsville hospital under the health care authority
Many of you may not know that if you face problems in paying your utility bill
And now you are unable to pay your medical bill that the hospital can place a lien against you
You could lose everything and that's why we are seeing such a rise
in homelessness
But one of the most important things that I am still concerned about is that four million dollar deficit
And we keep brushing past it and I will bring it up every time whether it be here or on social media
Because I think as we all have seen now social media is a very powerful force
The one concern i'm also
Going to bring up is we have a city administrator. I'd like to see that in your budgets
Miss penny smith, I'd like an answer
I'd like an answer council persons. I'd like an answer
And this is why our city is changing young people are looking for answers. We're looking for responsiveness
This past week one of my neighbors ironically an attorney asked me to look at another
citizens bill of
1601 dollars
It took me three days to get my mind around that before I made a few calls to huntsville utilities and they corrected that person's bill
by
591 dollars and change
It's very rare that you see the doctor help the attorney, but this was the case
There is too much in regards to misreads from a utility company that is still not representing accountability and transparency
As well as getting those books
And just like this young man was saying with the flock cameras, etc
We have open record laws
And what you don't realize is that these young people if they're not getting the answers here
They will take this to social media and the world will see it. Thank you
Thank you. Dr. Somerset. We'll now hear from tyler gottney who will be followed by dana holiday holifield
Hey, I am uh tyler gottney, uh huntsville district five my address is on the sheet. Thank you. I'm here to um
Speak out up against flock. I know the little worm that's
Warming its way throughout your head
Flock you have no reason reasonable expectation of privacy in public and it's collecting public data
But my argument hinges on a recent supreme court ruling in june of this year chattery of united states
the supreme court
Uh pontificated the stance that individuals have a reasonable expectation of privacy in the whole of their movements and flock is
fundamentally tracking those movements
It further reasons against surveillance technology offering newfound tracking capacity technology that runs against everyone
Not just those under investigation and technology that can travel back in time
The court's reasoning provided that location history is protected under the fourth amendment as follows
Location history provides an even more fine-tuned picture of a person's movement location history allows police to reconstruct
retrospectively and with no real effort
People's comings and goings in any area enabling tireless and absolute surveillance of any number of people in any number of places
Location history implicates personal privacy interests because location history is the individual's own in that way location history resembles other private
materials
That even if stored on a private company servers a user reasonably expects to be shielded from the inquisitive eyes of the government
The court's reference also referenced prior land warrant rulings on privacy such as carpenter v
carpenter v united states where
It ruled that acquisitions of a phone csli data constitutes a protected fourth amendment search in united states v jones
It ruled that attaching a gps device to a vehicle and then using the device to monitor the vehicles movements constitutes a fourth amendment search
in united states via
De re
They read
Fourth amendment is designed to place obstacles in the way of two permeating
permeating police surveillance
How then can you argue in good faith that a mass surveillance network such as alpr?
Technology where the movements of people are easily discoverable and a tireless and absolute surveillance network allows parallel
Reconstruction of for anything that they want to charge a person is not fourth amendment private protected domain
The other argument commonly is that you have nothing to hide if you have you have nothing to fear if
You have nothing to hide, but it indicates that the speaker fundamentally demands
We justify our desire for governmental boundaries
It is unamerica and I unamerican and I shouldn't have to explain to my thick-headed politicians
Why I'm glad I don't live in a surveillance state like China or Russia
The nothing to hide argument uses sample data
The nothing to hide argument uses sound circular reasoning to present a false dichotomy to people
And another common argument is that the national movement, thank you, sir, that's the end of your time
Well now our last speaker will be dana holiday. Holyfield
Thank you, my name is dana holiday. Holyfield. I live at 10010 strong drive
Southeast huntsville and my mother-in-law i'm here with to represent her as well. She lives at 4301 homes avenue northwest
so, um, I know that tara bailey has spoken to several of y'all about
Removing the sales tax on hearing aids
The state did that back in
2024 and madison city followed suit and I don't think a lot of people realize that
You know that that is taxed and it's a significant amount
It's 4.5 percent and I went with my mother-in-law to get her hearing aids and that was hundreds of dollars
Extra dollars that she is on a budget
we're talking about an 83 year old woman who every dollar counts and
that
4.5 percent on those expensive hearing aids
Is you know some for some people it may be the matter of groceries or getting my medication
so
Um when they don't have their hearing aids as a nurse, I see what that means. We're talking about social isolation
People feeling like they're left out of the conversation that they can't interact it can lead to depression
We're talking about people just feeling like you know, they're old
You know and going through all these things and then now they can't even participate in conversations
Um, so I feel like we need to follow suit and provide a resolution to remove that sales tax
It's not that much
I don't think it's going to impact the budget that much to remove that but it could really mean a lot to some
of our senior citizens
um and
Making a difference in their lives
So I would really like for y'all to consider bringing a resolution
Forth so that we can remove that cell tax and follow suit with what the state has done what madison city's done
We need to go ahead and get this done. I know um, several of you have spoken with tara bailey and myself
Please let's consider getting that done. I appreciate y'all's time and I always appreciate your service. Thank you. Thank you. Miss hollifield
That's our final speaker and concludes um all the items on our agenda is there a motion to adjourn move motion from
Mr. Little and we are adjourned. It is 7 54 pm
You